apologies for the crappy uh sound
quality and the hair but
let's just let's let's just go for it
let's make it look like an amp i uh just
got back from the gym here and i'm
working on my unfinished
office it's in my garage it's going to
be a study but look look i can see the
uh
the lake there so um listen first off i
appreciate everyone uh who came out
uh to the rally in michigan and
obviously no show today we'll be doing
the vp debate
megan kelly will be there for pre-gaming
i know some of you may not be fans but
considering that she hosted some debates
before i think she'll have some insight
um this is one of those topics now where
uh i see a lot of i see a lot of you out
there i see a lot of conservatives
and i see a lot of left-wingers but
particularly a lot of conservatives
um find themselves hopeless or motivated
they really rise and fall by the polls
and it's a question that i probably get
asked the most often
lately is um should we trust the polls
and you know what the truth is i don't
know let me offer you some
some personal anecdotes here
particularly as it relates to lansing
um because that's about all we have
to go on i shouldn't say all we have to
go on but the polls have been
consistently unreliable
um i will let me start with this
is there still a secret trump voter
right this is something that people talk
about quite a bit
um well they've accounted for this
secret trump voter they didn't account
for in 2016.
i don't know i think there are more
because back in 2016 while we knew
people hated trump
you didn't get shot in the chest point
blank
for having a moga hat right you didn't
get your businesses burned down
um and i will say this being in michigan
i've been spending quite a bit of time
here
in michigan again this is anecdotal
i know at least half a dozen businesses
that are trump voters who had signs up
in 2016
who who don't have them up now um and i
know more
people personally who had trump signs up
who don't have it up now there was
actually a beautiful barn
here um in rural michigan that had a
full uh
maga display homage there and now it's
just painted red with an american flag
um by the way i've also noticed that
it's either a biden harris
sign or an american flag one or the
other uh i'm sure there are exceptions
so should we trust the polls here's the
most important thing
don't allow your demeanor your spirit
your grit to be determined by
what somebody else tells you um
anyone who says that uh
trump is definitely gonna win in a
landslide you shouldn't trust these
polls
i completely discount for the same
reason that i discount people who say
trump has no chance to look at the polls
the truth lies somewhere in the middle
and if you look at the electoral map and
i'll tell you this i was as surprised as
anyone
who i'm sorry my thing my hand and
finger name my fingers getting sore
why does that happen is it is this
something for my hair this is
look look i accidentally i accidentally
got the devin salah
now lead pipe is gonna go straight
through the back of my head
someone got that film reference um i was
really shocked to see michigan go red
and i will tell you what i have seen in
michigan we've seen a changing of the
map
but not necessarily a changing of the
states in michigan the people who
consistently voted democrat right the
union voters
and by the way the unions still give
overwhelmingly to democrats and it's
it's if you look at i think you can go
to open secrets and see the top
political donors of all time
unions are far and away the top
political donors i mean big oil doesn't
even crack i don't think the top ten
uh so the union the heads of the unions
themselves give
98 to 100 democrats which also tells you
just like the media they're not
representative of their constituency
because i see a lot of
working class factory line union voters
now
who are ultimately trump supporters but
the people who are supporting
biden harris in michigan now are what
were once seen as
republicans the mitt romney let's find
out mitt romney i mean he claims
massachusetts is from michigan and then
he just spotted a seat in utah and
you know he got elected there because he
was he was a mormon um
not to say anything against mormons i'm
sure mormons are just as disappointed
with romney as i am but he specifically
sought out a place where he could win a
seat in utah
um but the romneys and the rick snyders
of the world former republican governor
of michigan
have endorsed biden he made a lot of his
money i believe in dell
so the rich elite are supporting biden
hares
and the working class in michigan uh
tend to be supporting donald trump so
there is a switching
which i think is pretty hard to monitor
with the polls and
let me tell you this too um something
anecdotal but you know if
i don't do a lot of press uh and i did
some more press for the celeste this
lansing rally because you know it was it
was near and dear to my heart i have a
97 year old grandma
in uh in michigan by the way uh
hashtag whitmer death toll let's send
all of our freedom of information
requests
to governor whitmer to get those numbers
released you can go to lotterycredit.com
get the signs
printed out so we held this uh rally in
lansing
you know you know i don't really like to
talk about numbers so much because we've
seen so many conservatives and liberals
who rising fall by numbers
look we're the biggest show look at how
many people are watching look at uh
how great we are because of uh the polls
if you will
um i think it's a metric that that
is important in that it sort of tells us
how many lives we're affecting
but we could very easily make that the
only metric and start affecting lives
less and let me explain what i mean
there have been opportunities right to
syndicate the show to get it out on
cable
to um change in which case we have to
change the dynamic of the show
would we reach more people sure would we
be able to make the same show no
not at all so i don't like to talk about
numbers because i've had shows that have
been
really big or successful that i haven't
necessarily been super happy with and
we've had small shows where i feel like
we've really served
you guys and mug club really well um but
the lansing rally happened so i did a
little bit more press which is
out of the ordinary for me because we
don't really need to we have enough of a
platform
and we showed up and we did this lansing
rally and we gave out thousands of signs
and uh there was some coverage and by
the way it was it was
it wasn't really vicious from m live is
like the biggest michigan uh
publication i think anyway at least the
biggest website and then the lansing
state journal
and uh first off it shows you how
inconsistent
the media like they just guess and they
act as though they're authoritative
uh mli said uh a thousand people showed
up
to the lansing rally and then uh the
lansing state journal said uh
hundreds of people okay again
not the numbers not that the numbers
themselves matter what matters is that
these are considered authoritative
sources
listen the low end estimate was at least
2500 the high end was 3 500 we had a
perfect
we had professional security there we
have someone who specializes
in sort of head counting doing groups uh
and i can tell you this
we printed out a thousand seventy signs
i know that because the whitmer death
toll signs were a thousand i think we
had 70 lujan whitmer
they were gone immediately and we had
far more people who complained that they
didn't get signs than people who even
picked up signs so
we know it was you can you can go watch
the video at least 3 000 people but this
is
what happens right you can look at the
reporting from this writer at m live
and and i don't say this to for you to
go and attack them on twitter like that
i don't really harbor any ill will it's
sort of like
listen when a child is misbehaving it's
the parents fault when a journalist is
doing what journalists
do um it's the fault of the publications
it's a fault of the industry
we really wish that journalists
weren't what they be but they do so um
you see this in the media and they cover
hundreds and then one says a thousand
and it was about three thousand
something people well why would they do
that
and by the way i've seen quite a few
signs the whitmer death toll signs go up
in michigan so michiganders out there
continue posting it
they put that up there because they want
to demoralize people and think well
there really aren't enough people who
are rallying against this
torrent this little authoritarian that
could governor whitmer
you know what so just just really stay
home because
there's nothing going on here there's
nothing to see so i will say this i do
think that
and this happens in my personal
experience and nearly every run we've
had with media when they say they're
looking to report on an issue
they're misleading right they're just
not telling you the truth you saw that
with the austin chronicle
um i can't remember all of them i think
it might have been a washington post
article before
uh vox the
polls have become um
just as much of a tool to manipulate
public opinion
as they once were to reflect public
opinion
now i don't know this is anyone's game
at this point
maybe i'm rambling a little bit but this
is absolutely anyone's game
anyone who tells you that there's a
guaranteed win on either side
is lying they're not telling you the
truth no one can predict that the vegas
betting odds can't predict that
nate silver couldn't predict last time a
lot of people were wrong and that's why
i avoid making political predictions and
i tell you this
it doesn't change what i do and it
shouldn't change what you do
this is what i think is most important
regardless of the polls going into the
election you need to vote
you need to mobilize people to vote uh
in person preferably so you know it
counts it doesn't get tossed in a dish
somewhere
um but let's say that donald trump loses
like i said i think it's anyone's game
at this point it doesn't change what you
do i was recently being interviewed by a
reporter he said well what happens uh
what are you gonna do if uh
if donald trump loses think about this
for a second
the leftist media uh and the online left
media by the way people people like
people like vox and i am recording a
cell phone video
no respect no respect
um made life so
uh i think i think it actually might
have been my dad he needs michael doing
something with a hammer
uh he's old you know brittle's hands
so someone said what what are you going
to do if trump blew this look if you go
back to the obama era right when this is
where you had boxing msnbc
um and the young turks they started
losing
viewership and they started losing uh
this is this whole thing i'm sorry it's
just it has a life of its own life of
its own
they started losing um
[Music]
public trust while obama was president
why
here's why sure the white house changed
from obama to donald trump
but when obama was in the white house
for example let's use the young turks or
some or a
daily show or colbert any of these
people i think there was still a comedy
central
they were only cheerleaders think of
this for a second because if you work in
the media well everyone in the media is
left we know that i mean
for granted now is stephanopoulos there
doing intent this guy worked for the
clintons as
a communications director okay
um you have a leftist media a leftist
entertainment industry
and then you also happen to have a
leftist in the white house who was
whisked into the white house
by the uh aforementioned establishments
the only thing that changed was donald
trump became president
now we continually were gaining viewers
and trust and subscribers when obama was
president
and while donald trump was president why
because the fight the rebellion that i
think all of us uh
take pride in being a part of is not
just about who's in the white house if
you would take the power of exclusively
the white house over
um hollywood and entertainment industry
and the media you need a cat scan
and that's why donald trump is frankly
the only president that i've seen who
has been effectively waging a war
against bias media which i think
is long overdue and i don't think that
any other president would have done that
at this time you
you let me know i was a ted cruz
supporter in the primary he's been on
the show he's in front of the show i
like him too i don't think that anyone
out there
would have been waging a war and shining
a light on the bias media as they do now
so what happens if donald trump wins or
loses
what we do is the same thing first off
come election day we're gonna go out and
vote then after election day guess what
we're going to be doing
we're going to be sharing the light on
the truth and entertaining people it
doesn't matter if donald trump is
president or joe biden is president now
it matters obviously for the sake of the
country but i'm talking about our job
our job is still to point out corruption
and to point out double standards and to
laugh at them
right humor is a rubber tipped sword i
think phyllis diller said that it's a
way to
make a point without drawing blood you
think that if joe biden is president
we're not going to have anything to
rebel against we're not going to have a
fight we're not going to have a way to
get
that's why conservatives tend to come
out in midterms we're always mobilized
because every institution in the country
right now
is stacked against you with the
exception of the white house and senate
thank god
amy coney barrett so i i guess i say
this because
it's a question that i get so often what
about the polls what about the polls
well i can tell you
anecdotally that i don't trust a lot of
what the media tells us because they
were wrong before and in my personal
experience even as recently as
lansing where they said hundreds of
people showed up when it was three
thousand
they have a vested interest in making
you feel hopeless
okay but it's on you to not allow that
to
happen when i see people depressed out
there who are conservatives like what
are you
what are you doing what is this all for
if you're if you're
well if you're moping around there's so
much for us to do
first off yeah to maintain uh
a man who represents our values in the
white house
but even if there's so much that you
have to do on a day-to-day basis rather
than feeling upset
rather than just bitching about go out
and change something go out and do
something it shouldn't change what you
do it shouldn't change who you are
and as conservatives inherently as woody
allen said we just have we haven't we
have a general
problem with authority and guess what
the authority isn't only the white house
so i want you to keep that in mind and
something else by the way um
i saw i don't know if i can bring this
up maybe i can toss an overlay in
a recent abstract pretty extensive study
on on masks and this will get fact
checked
in uh scientific reports so it was a
published
study and if you guys can read this i'll
put the link down below
it seems like it says throughout the
entire study that uh n95 masks obviously
are effective at reducing
droplets and aerosols but homemade cloth
masks
actually increase the aerosol droplets
several fold in coughing in talking
and then at the end says well though we
do think that masks can be effective
so every single paragraph i read shows
that
actually the homemade cotton nests are
doing more harm than good
but the conclusion doesn't seem to match
the results or the study so
again i'm not a scientist here i don't
want youtube to fact check this and take
it down like they did when we were
actually recommending
masks if you were sick then remember
that in mug club quarantine month we had
origin main a sponsor
uh of ours actually just friends of ours
they weren't really officially sponsors
of
uh i think jaco works with them and
makes some jiu jitsu and they were
making masks and we said hey good idea
maybe get some asks we were fact checked
on youtube here
and then it said a link to the cdc where
at that point they were saying don't
wear masks it does more harm than good
now there's another study where every
single paragraph seems to read again
it's in scientific reports here i'll put
the link down below
that masks cotton masks not n95 nests
do more harm than good and then in
conclusion but you know
uh they're still probably a good idea so
scientists out there let me know i'm
just a big old dummy i'm sure reading
this because
us peasants shouldn't be allowed to read
these studies uh as for everyone else
listen
again go to letters federal.com uh uh
you michiganders and get your site you
can just print your signs everything is
free you can print them we gave out the
signs for you can print the whitmer
death toll signs yourself
from the website you can submit your
freedom of uh your foia
um request for the actual death numbers
and don't let by the way don't let the
media tell you that
the only reason those 442 uh 447 homes
were included were was because those
were the only ones affected
because 25 of all deaths in any given
week month here
come from old folks homes so does that
mean there were 1900 additional deaths
again we need to know the baseline
baseline budgeting
governor whitmer and democrats you
should know about that right that's why
we'll see
19 guys on the side of the road to fix a
pothole that for some reason
the next week is still there i don't
know what um
everyone else out there i i do want you
to keep this in mind
be happy warriors go forward take
everything with a grain of salt
it is anybody's game at this point that
means that you need to be mobilized that
you need to be
active and um win lose or draw
it shouldn't change who we are it
doesn't change what we do
tuesday night the vp debates megan kelly
will be there we'll have drinking game
rules
um i'm looking forward to seeing you and
maybe you should just get a buzz cut